[Music]
Good evening. Um, I'm calling the
finance committee meeting for April
21st, 2025 to order. And we have several
resolutions to go over. First of one is
resolution uh temporary resolution
38-25, a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services
associated with flow monitoring.
Monitoring to be conducted
uh within the River Valley Highland
subdivision sanitary sewer system come
from water uh waste water pollution. Uh,
Councilman Wayne. Uh, yes. Thank you,
Mr. Chairman. Um, you may remember this
piece. It was briefly discussed last
week. Um, coming up this week, uh, this
is for the sanitary sewer flow
monitoring study in River Valley
Highlands. Uh, there have been some
issues up there, which is, uh, is why we
need the study. Uh, the legislation in
front of us authorizes $250,000
uh, for the study. uh if we have enough
rain events, it shouldn't take uh
shouldn't take that much, but that there
is some contingency built in in case we
don't have very many rain events. And
again, this is we've discussed this
before, but if Curtis or Stephen wanted
to add anything or answer any questions,
you're welcome to come up.
Stephen loves to talk.
Good evening, everybody. Well,
Councilman Wing did a nice job. I don't
know that I have much really to add. I
just I guess I'd come up uh and answer
any questions if there uh might be any
from any council members tonight.
Any questions of council? No.
All right. Never thought I'd say this,
but let's hope it rains.
All right. Uh that'll be three readings
and I have Councilwoman Tener is my
second. Perfect. Thank you. Yep. Thank
you. Uh you're probably Denise here
tonight. Okay. I wasn't sure who's going
to do which one. So anyway, now we have
temporary resolution
39-25, a resolution to increase
receipts, appropriate funds in the
wastewater reserve fund 6029, amend the
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the county auditor,
and authorize payment of bills uh with
then and now certificates for the water
development loan for the solid handling
uh facility upgrade project again coming
from water wastewater council wing.
Yeah, thank you Mr. Chairman. Uh most of
you probably remember we approved the uh
solids handling facility on Laurens
Street uh several meetings ago. Um this
just appropriates the money for that
project from the wastewater reserve fund
and uh the OWDA application was approved
and I believe work is progressing on
schedule. So uh Denise, you're welcome
to whoever was welcome to come up and
speak on this and correct me if I'm
wrong on that.
Uh yes, we have signed contracts uh with
Reich Brothers who is also doing the um
disinfection project at the South Water
Plant. So we're very familiar with them.
Um and all this does is it it's
bookkeeping for the auditor. When OWDA
makes a payment, we have to put it on
our books and this takes care of it.
Okay. All right. Any questions?
This will be three readings and I uh
Councilman Als is my second.
All righty. Thank
you. Now we have temporary ordinance
40-25, a resolution to increase receipts
appropriate funds in the storm water
utility reserve fund 6019. Amended
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the Den and Dow
certificates for the Ohio Water
Development Loan uh for the East Main
Street sewer separation project. again
coming from water waste water pollution.
Yes. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh again,
this is another project we've discussed
several times. Uh this piece
appropriates uh the money from the storm
water utility reserve fund for the East
Main Street uh sewer separation project
which is already underway and if you on
the east side of town have probably seen
that already. So I don't have anything
to add. Okay. I have Councilwoman
Tiner's my second and three readings.
Perfect. Thank you. Temporary resolution
41-25, a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to dispense with
competitive bidding due to a sole source
provider for me for membrane replacement
at the upper hawking water pollution
control facility and a water wastewater
or water pollution control committee. Uh
yes, thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh now
that phase two of Upper Hawking is is uh
getting started, it is time to replace
the membranes in phase one. Uh these
membranes are about 15 years old, I
believe, and were originally produced by
Mecor. I think they're the only company
that produces those membranes and so
that's the the need for the soul source
legislation. Anything to add on that or
just answer any questions? Okay,
questions.
Good. Okay. I have Councilman Nails as
my second and three readings. Very good.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank both you and
Stephen.
Okay. Temporary resolution
42-25, a resolution to authorize the
city of Lancaster to apply for funding
from Ohio Department of Development for
CHIP program funds coming from Economic
Development Committee. Uh, Councilman
Hoop. Yes. Hope I make it through my
voice. You're good. Um, yes. This just
allows us to apply for the CHIP program
for up to 250,000. I think Chasin was
going to come
up to give us a little more information.
Hi, good evening. Um, so the 2026 cycle
of the CHIP, the community housing
impact and preservation grant is
projected to be released in May. Um,
this request is just for approval to
apply for this next round of funding.
Just a quick little background. Um the
typical award amount is
$250,000 and this allows us to renovate
five or six houses. Um this is a full
renovation grant which means that we fix
whatever we find that needs to be fixed
up um up to the $85,000 cap. The grant
cycle runs it should be awarded by
December 1st of this year and then it
will run till April 30th of
2028. Um, and that's when we have to
have that fully closed out.
Any questions?
I think there are any questions. So, um,
Mrs. K is going to be my second and we
want three readings. Very good. Thank
you.
Temporary resolution
44-25, a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance, amend the
certificate with the county auditor in
the cemetery fund 2007
uh to authorize the service safety
director to purchase a replacement
vehicle for use by the cemetery
department supervisor and to declare an
emergency coming from public works
committee. Uh, Councilman Davis,
Chairman, Chairman Wolfinger, we we have
to go back to 4325.
Oh, did I skip over that? Yeah,
I apologize for that. I was,
but we can do we can do 44. We'll do 44
and we'll come back. Thank you. I think
you should have to read it all over
again.
Anyway, so we'd had a uh a vehicle that
got in a bit of an accident. Was not our
fault. And so this is uh for uh we've
got money from the other insurance
company that Tim you want to come up and
answer any questions?
Uh really to look at it as old as the
vehicle was and then we've got money. It
it is to to me does make sense to go
ahead. Um usually I'm not okay with it,
but if we would uh buy something used
then we would have to get a warranty and
that cost more money. So this way it's
under warranty. So, yes, this is the
legislation I warned you about last
council meeting. Um, so basically,
um, they did total it out. They're going
to give us a little over $19,000 for the
old truck, um, which had 77,000 miles on
it at the time. And then, uh, we've got
a new truck we have a quote for sitting
on the lot at, um,
Helm, I think it's Helm or Hugh White,
sorry. and um it's ready to go. So, but
the quotes only good through May 3rd,
which is before the next council
meeting. So, that's why you'll see one
reading request. Um any other question?
So, if we bought it the used one and had
a warranty, it wouldn't even cover it
all anyway. A lot of the stuff wouldn't
even be covered. The used warranties
typically nobody warranties a truck
that's older than three years. But up
within that first three years, you got
they don't come with a standard warranty
because they're used. So depending what
you want
to cover, you you pay for what you want
to cover. So typically like a bumperto
bumper would be at a three-year bumper
to bumper, but you're going to start at
$3500 and up depending all all you want
to include in this. The new truck does
come with um bumper-to-bumper three-year
warranty. It's got a 5-year warranty on
the drivetrain, um, which is all
included in the price, and there's three
other warranty packages that are all
lumped into that, too, depending on, um,
electrical, all that kind of stuff. So,
we're we we went out, we did get pricing
on 10 used vehicles and, um, the average
cost across those 10,
$28,000. Our thought was $45,000 for the
new one plus the 19 we're going to get
puts us about
$26,000 and it's ready to roll except
for uh we do need a toolbox in the back
of the one and then a stroke kit for the
top cuz we do um lead funeral
processions in and out of the cemetery.
So
I have a question. Sure. Uh what are the
additional costs that will be um the
strobe kit? Well, whatever was needed.
Um I've I've got a not to exceed $510 in
here because I'm asking for $46,000. So
um we can get a toolbox relatively
cheaply and u we've got some light kits
that are in stock if we need an extra
power pack or anything for those.
They're not that expensive. So All
right. Thank you. My mechanics are told
not to go over $510. Thank you. Did the
toolbox get damaged in the other in the
accident? The other truck didn't have a
toolbox. It actually had a bed cover um
which was a solid thing that kind of
lifted up. Okay. So, you can't transfer
anything over to this one. It did. On
top of that, it's two different makes of
vehicle. We get rid of a Dodge and a
Chevy. So, okay. They're not
transferable anyway.
Anything else? Anything else?
Okay. And Christina Kits, please my
second you're asking for suspension.
Suspension tonight. Yes. Any
objections here? No. Go ahead. Thank
you. Thanks.
And this is 43. Temporary resolution
43-25, a resolution to amend the
certificate of appropriations for the
county otter appropriate from the
unencumbered balance increase receipts
complete fund transfer and CWG loan
repay revolving credit fund 2075 and in
the community development of block grant
fund 2073 and declare an emergency. uh
coming from economic development
committee and Councilman Hoop. Um yes,
thank you. This is just to transfer some
money and Chasin's going to come up with
more
information. So, um HUD, the Department
of Housing and Urban Development
requires recipients to use program
income before spending the grant funds.
So, the program income is generated
through the leans put on the projects.
um program income has to be used for a
like purpose. So, it has to go back into
rehab because that's how the income was
created. For the past couple of years,
Housing and Neighborhoods, formerly
Community Development, has been waiting
on HUD to approve a reconciliation for
the program income. Um these funds could
not be used until it was fully
reconciled and that was finally approved
last December. Um, our request is to
transfer 25,000 from the CDBG loan repay
revolving account fund 2075 to the
community development block grant fund
2073 in order to use these funds in
alignment with the requirements outlined
by
HUD. Okay, any questions?
Okay, thank
you. Um, Mr. Wing is going to be my
second and that can go three readings.
Okay. Thank you. Finally, we have
temporary resolution
45-25, a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance in the general
fund 10001. Increase receipts
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance in the health insurance
management fund 7022 and amend
certificate appropriations with the
county county auditor coming from
administrative services committee. and
that would be Councilman Lber. Thank
you, Mr. Chairman. Uh, prior to the
collective bargaining agreements that
the city uh reached with its employees
several years ago, the city had offered
self-insured life insurance policies to
the
employees. And uh since then, the city's
never had more than one claim a year.
And so, we budgeted 10,000 this year,
and we've had four claims come in this
year. that 10,000 will cover for three
of them uh but not the fourth. So, we're
asking for $11,000 additional to cover
for the fourth and any potential
additional claims it might hit this
year. So, with this resolution, we're
just asking to appropriate the
additional 11,000 bucks. Okay. And
Councilman Bischek will be my second.
Three readings. Three readings. Thank
you.
That's it for the uh resolutions for
tonight. Uh we have no audiences to come
before for first reading. I will move on
to other discussion items. Uh first
would be departmental updates.
Yes. Since there are no other
departmental updates, I will just go
ahead and update that our city hall
renovation project uh that bid should be
going live later this week. We have uh
the legal notice needed to be into the
gazette by Wednesday at noon. So our
engineers office is handling that uh
working with our architect to get that
into the gazette for the public notice
and then it will go live on Friday. So
as soon as that's live, I will keep you
all posted.
Thank you. Any uh questions of
council? Thank you very much for the
update. Any other updates?
Okay, moving on to tonight's meeting
prep. President Porter. Thank you,
Chairman Wolfinger. Tonight for tonight
meeting, we have 17 resolutions on the
agenda along with six ordinances. We
also have a public hearing regarding the
powers run tiff.
Thank
you.
Any other items to for finance committee
for anybody wants to bring
up? I see no hands. Uh we will not have
an executive session tonight and I would
look for a motion to adjurnn. So moved.
Second. All those in favor please
signify by saying I. I. And we are
adjourned. and it is
6:16 almost an hour less than last week.
That's a that's a record for a finance
committee agenda. So, thank you. We will
convene the regular meeting of Lancaster
City Council promptly at 6:30.
[Music]
The Frankie Smith Funeral Home and
Crematory in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community. Feel free to give us a
call at
74-653652. Stop in and see us at either
of our two locations, 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore. Respect for
tradition, regard for change.
Hi, I'm Karen Martin with After School
Programs of Lancaster. We're here to
provide programs and services to support
educational, social, and cultural
opportunities for our students. This
month, we're thrilled that Buckeye
Toyota and Buckeye Honda have reached
out once again to offer their support
through their Buckeye Cares program by
making a generous donation with each car
sold this month. Join me and many others
in supporting local business and you
might just find yourself saying that's
how I buck eye.
[Music]
God grant us the serenity to accept the
things that we cannot change, the
courage courage to change the things we
can and finally the wisdom to know the
difference. Please join me in the pledge
of allegiance.
I pledge algiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
I call the April 21st, 2025 Lancaster
City Council meeting to order.
Would we please call the role? Mr. Als
here, Mr. Bisjack here, Mrs. Kra here,
Mrs. Hoop here, Mr. Lochnberg here, Mr.
Skunover here, Mr. Sullie here, Miss
Teener here, Mr. Wing here, and Mr.
Wolfinger here. Uh let the record
reflect that all 10 members of Lancaster
City Council are here this evening. Uh
just a gentle reminder for everybody to
make sure that your microphone is on and
in within range. Um reading and
disposing of the journal of regular
meeting minutes dated April 7th, 2025.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the journal. Second.
We have a motion and second to receive
and file the journal. All those in
favor, please signify by saying I. I.
All those opposed, same sign. We'll now
move on to the reports of city
officials. I have three email dated
April 14th, 2025 regarding East Main
Street sewer separation project
submitted by storm water manager Steven
Welstead and forwarded by Mayor
McDaniel. Email dated April 16, 2025.
Cemetery pickup truck replacement
submitted by Superintendent M or
attendees. Email dated April 17, 2025.
Um, Zayn Alley sewer replacement
information update submitted by service
safety director Woody. Mr. President,
I'd like to make a motion to receive and
file the reports of city officials.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
receive and file the reports of city
officials. All those in favor, please
signify by saying I.
All those opposed, same sign. Now move
on to communications. I do have one
email dated April 10th, 2025 regarding
blue label annexation public hearing
submitted by David Hodgej with Underh
Hill and Hodge LLC.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the communications.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
receive and file the communications. All
those in favor, please signify by saying
I. I. All those opposed, same sign.
Thank you. We have no special
presentations or awards this evening, no
petitions or memorials. At this time, we
have reached the se section of our
agenda which is our permission of voters
and taxpayers to address council. Uh
this is separate and aside from the um
public hearing on the powers run tiff.
Our rules are such that you can address
council for three minutes. Um, you would
come to the podium, sign the green, uh,
clipboard with your name and address,
uh, say your name and address, and you
would have three minutes to address
council. Is there anybody here uh, who
wishes to address city council this
evening? We do see an individual coming
to the podium. Ma'am, you have three
minutes. Good evening, council members.
This Saturday, if you want to have uh
your faith and humanity restored, I
invite you to come downtown for
Destination Downtown Lancaster's annual
downtown cleanup day, we have 250
volunteers signed up. Uh and it is a
wonderful time to connect with your
neighbors, your constituents, other
community leaders, business leaders, uh
and make downtown sparkle a little bit
more. If you're unable to come down and
join us at 8:30 in the morning uh on
Saturday at the gazebo and then spread
throughout the downtown, uh please feel
free to host a pop-up cleanup day in
your own neighborhoods, in your own
wards. Uh I highly encourage it. It's a
great way to meet your constituents,
meet your neighbors, and have some time
to build community. I hope that we see
you all there, and if you have any
questions, please feel free to reach out
to me. I will tell you, thanks to Brad
Hutchinson, you do get a free lunch out
of it. And thanks to Destination
Downtown Lancaster, a pretty super cool
tie-dye t-shirt. So, we hope to see you
there. Thank you.
Is there anybody else who wishes to Here
we go. We have another individual. This
guy. You might just put a You might just
put Yeah. Yeah. Put some dashes under
your dress. Good evening, council. My
name is Brian Everett. I reside at 201
South High Street. And I wanted to touch
base briefly with a topic I speak
frequently on, which is pedestrian
safety. As many of you are aware, uh
recently there was an individual that
was hit by a car on East Main Street.
That individual is um suffering
significant injuries and currently
remains in the hospital. uh and
certainly hope that he does recover. But
I think it speaks to the condition of
our infrastructure and transportation
network in our city that walking to get
ice cream can potentially result in
heinous injuries or death. Um and that's
not where we should be and that's not
where we have to be. Were our
infrastructure properly designed, um it
would be physically impossible for
vehicles to reach the speeds necessary
to jump the curbs, to get past barriers,
and to hit a pedestrian like that. Um,
and we very frequently see buildings,
pedestrians, other vehicles, we're
talking about replacing one here, get
hit by cars that should not be able to
go as fast as they're going. I would
encourage council to not only continue
to look at this, but also to take some
action. And action doesn't necessarily
have to cost money. Action can be
incorporated through programs we already
have in place or through low cost or no
cost. Some examples would be visually
narrowing, which is a fancy term for
using paint to make drivers think they
should go slower. We have a tree
commission that is seeking to continue
to place or replace trees. Those can be
installed in tree lawns that are then
barriers to prevent vehicles from
getting onto those sidewalks where
pedestrians are walking, people are
pushing strollers, etc. Um, you can do
daylighting, which is uh intersections,
pylons and paint that prevent cars from
parking past the no parking signs and
make it so that pedestrians do not have
to walk out into the road to see if it
is cleared to cross. There's a lot of
again lowcost, no cost or already in
place systems that can be used to
address this so that all of our
community is safe. And statistics show
that when pedestrians and bicycle riders
and other people using multimodal
transit are safer, people in vehicles
are also safer. Thank you. Thank you.
Is there anybody else who would like to
address city council this
evening? Seeing none, we thank you for
coming to tonight's meeting.
We have any reports of standing
committees? I have finance committee
meeting minutes dated April 7, 2025
submitted by Mr. Wolfinger.
Administrative service committee agenda
dated April 16, 2025 submitted by Mr.
Luenberg. Uh finance committee agenda
dated April 18, 2025 submitted by Mr.
Wolfinger. And finally, a water water
pollution committee minute meeting
meeting minutes dated April 20th, 2025
submitted by Mr. Wing.
Mr. President, like to make a motion to
receive and file the reports of standing
committees. Second. We have a motion and
a second to receive and file the reports
of standing committees. All those in
favor, please signify by saying I. I.
All those opposed, same sign. Reports of
special committees. There are no reports
of special committees to present this
evening. Thank you. We have now reached
the time in our meeting uh for the
public hearing regarding the powers run
tiff. Uh the rules associated with the
public hearing are such that if you are
speaking as a proponent, you will come
to the podium uh sign in, give your name
and address as a proponent in favor of
the tiff and you will have three minutes
to speak. Then after all of the
proponents have had their opportunity to
speak, we will hear from the opponents.
uh to the powers run tiff. Same rules
apply. Sign in three minutes to speak
for each speaker. And then finally at
the end there is a rebuttal. Uh rebuttal
can come from the proponents have chosen
only those who have chosen to speak the
first time um in tonight's meeting. So
um if there's any questions about that
as we go on uh we will be happy to
clarify that for you. Um, first up in
the hearing, we will be hearing from law
director Hall.
Good evening everybody. I'm here to
represent the city. Um, and this is a a
tiff that is put forward by the city in
exchange and tiff stands for tax
increment financing. Um, for anybody who
wasn't aware. Um, and this is a tiff
that the city has arranged to give to
the developer who is going to put in uh
333 single family homes on approximately
128 acres. Um, the expenses for all of
the the public utilities, the roads, all
of that um are going to be about $21
million. And obviously the city of
Lancaster doesn't have $21 million to
put into infrastructure like that. And
so the developer is going to pay that
and then the tiff is going to pay them
back. and the tiff will pay them back
over a period of 30 years. It's not
going to pay back the entire $21
million. Whatever the developer gets,
the developer gets. Um, but at that
point, we will have 333 new single
family homes, which the city of
Lancaster is in desperate need of. Um,
so just a quick explanation of the
notice that you all received. Um, it
should have basically two different
areas on it. First of all, there was an
area shaded in green and that is the
actual tiff district itself and then
there's a square around that or a
rectangle rather sometimes around that
area shaded in green and that's what's
called the incentive overlay. Anybody in
that incentive overlay uh your property
is not actually going to be affected
because parcels you know in the state of
Ohio can have some really weird shapes.
um the state legislature requires us to
draw essentially a shape around that
district that that can be verified,
right? So the best way for them to do
that is just a box or a rectangle. Um
and so that's why some of your
properties might look like they're going
to be affected by this, but the only
properties that will be affected in any
way are those that are shaded in green
and those belong to the developer. Um,
currently that's Mark and Beth Powers
who own the property, but they do have a
contract with FourStar who is going to
be developing that land for those single
family residences that I told you
about. If anybody has any questions, um,
you know, while you're up here, feel
free to get those out and when I come
back, um, I will try to address those
for you. Thanks.
Thank you, Law Director Hall.
So, do we have anybody here who wishes
to seek speak as a proponent for the
powers run tiff, meaning speak in
favor? Seeing none, we thank you for
coming. Next, we move on to opponents.
Is there anybody here who would like to
speak out against the proposed tiff?
Seeing none, we thank you for coming and
we're going to close this public hearing
at this time. Thank you for your
attendance at tonight's
meeting. We will now move on to the
reading of resolutions. Beginning with
the third reading of resolutions,
uh, temporary resolution 28-25,
a resolution to authorize the mayor to
enter into a contract with the Fairfield
County General Health District for
public health services. And Mrs.
Administrative Services Committee with
Mr. Luckenberg and Mr. Whinger. Council
member Leenberg. Thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record resolution
temporarily numbered 28-25.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
28-25. Uh any discussion? Council member
Luenberg. I thank you. Yes. Uh this is
just a year-to-year contract that the
city writes with the Fairfield County
Health Department to provide their
services to Lancaster. And this one is
for 2026 and represents just a 2%
increase from 2025. Thank you. Any
further discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role.
Excuse me. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bishack,
yes. Mrs. Kate, yes. Mrs. Hoop. Mr.
Lucknberg. Yes. Mr. Skunover. Yes. Mr.
Sully, yes. Miss Teener, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes. Temporary
resolution
28-25 passes 10 to zero. Temporary
resolution 29-25,
a resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the timber top tip
fund or 3060. This is through finance
committee, Mr. Wolfinger and Mr. Als.
Council member Wolfinger. Thank you, Mr.
President. I would like to make a motion
that city council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 29-25.
Second. We have a motion and second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
29-25. Any discussion? Council member
Wolfinger. Yes. This is a resolution
that will appropriate $76,000 of some
change uh that was carried over from
2024 that needs to be reappropriated
this year so it could be uh used. Thank
you. Any further
discussion hearing? None. Please call
the RO. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes.
Mrs. Kit, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Wuenberg, yes. Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr.
Sullive, yes. Miss Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes. Temporary
resolution
29-25 passes 10 to zero. Temporary
resolution 30-25,
a resolution of the city of Lancaster to
approve the Fairfield County E911 final
plan. This is through safety committee.
Mr. Bisjack and Miss Tiner. Council
member Bisjack. Thank you, Mr.
President. I move that council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
resolution temporarily numbered 30-25.
Second. We have a motion in a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
30-25. Council member Bisjack.
Discussion. Uh thank you, Mr. President.
Once again, this legislation seeks to
approve the Fairfield County E911 plan.
This is a countywide plan uh that all
municipalities are also uh required to
approve. Um this is to help with uh
getting better technologies within the
county uh specifically uh addressing uh
the need for better response times. So
that's all I have to say. Thank you. Any
further discussion hearing? None. Please
call the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr.
Bisshot, yes. Mrs. Kit, yes. Mrs. Hoop,
yes. Mr. Letoberg, yes. Mr. Skunover,
yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss Ter, yes. Mr.
Wing, yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes.
Temporary resolution 30-25. Passes 10 to
zero. We will now move on to the second
reading of resolutions, beginning with
temporary resolution 32-25.
A resolution to authorize all actions
necessary to accept Northeast Ohio
Public Energy Council 2025 Energized
Community Grants Funds. This is through
administrative service committee, Mr.
Luckenberg and Mr. Wolfinger. Council
member Luckenberg. Uh, thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council suspend its rules and wave
the third reading of resolution
temporarily number 32-25.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary resolution
32-25. Any discussion, council member?
Yes. Uh this is uh the city has replaced
aging light fixtures throughout city
hall with new energy efficient lights
and this resolution just allows the city
to enter into the 2025 NOPEC energized
community grant agreement to reimburse
the city for those lights. Thank you.
Any further discussion on the motion to
suspend?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kra,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Luenberg, yes.
Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Teener, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes. Motion to suspend the
rules and wave the third reading of
temporary resolution 32-25 passes 10 to
zero.
Council member Luckenberg. Uh, thank
you, Mr. President. I'd like to make a
motion that council pass a gross and
enter upon the written record.
Resolution temporarily numbered 3225.
Second. We have a motion and second to
pass gross and enter upon the written
record. Temporary resolutions
32-25. Any further discussion? Council
member Luenberg. Not at this time. Thank
you. Any further discussion from council
members?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kites,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Luckenberg.
Yes. Mr. Skoonover. Yes. Mr. Sully. Yes.
Miss Tiner. Yes. Mr. Wing. Yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger. Yes. Motion to pass and gross
and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution 32-25 passes 10 to
zero. We'll now move on to temporary
resolution 33-25.
A resolution to amend permanent
resolution
770-22 authorizing the service safety
director to enter into an engineering
agreement for various construction
administration and instruction services
during the north water treatment plant
replacement project and to increase
estimated receipts appropriate from an
unencumbered balance and amend their
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the county auditor
and the water utility reserve fund 602.
27. This is through water water
pollution with Mr. Wing and Mr. Als.
Council member Wing. This will be the
second of three readings. Second of
three readings on temporary resolution
33-25. Temporary resolution 34-25.
A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services on
the Frederick Street sewer separation
project. Again, this is through water
water pollution committee with Mr. Wing
and Miss Tiner. Council member Wing,
this is also the second of three
readings. Second of three readings on
temporary resolution
34-25. Temporary resolution 35-25.
A resolution authorizing the service
safety director to dispense with
competitive bidding and enter into a
contract with the Rosenberg, I'm sorry,
Rosenbar, South Dakota LLC for the
purchase of the 2026 Rosenbar Commander
Pumper Truck for the use by the
Lancaster Fire Department to appropriate
funds and and to declare an emergency.
This is through safety committee. Mr.
Bisjack and Mr. Sully, council member
Bisjack. Second of three readings. Thank
you, Mr. President. Second of three
readings on temporary resolution
35-25. Temporary resolution 36-25.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance. Amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the general fund 10001
to reimburse the link report authority
for paying its portion portional share
for the Fairfield County Housing Study.
This is through finance committee with
Mr. Wolfinger and Mr. Als. Council
member Wolfinger. Second of three
readings. Second of three readings on
temporary resolution
36-25. Temporary resolution 37-25.
A resolution to amend the certificate of
appropriations with the Fairfro County
Auditor and appropriate from the
unencumbered balance in the general fund
10001 for the addition of two deputy
clerk positions within the municipal
clerk's office and to declare an
emergency. Again, this is through
finance committee with Mr. Wolfinger and
Mr. Sully. Council member Wolfinger.
Thank you, Mr. President. I would like
to make a motion to replace temporary
resolution 37-25
uh with temporary resolution um 20 or
37-25 star.
Second, just one one quick law director,
do we just need to recite that that was
given in writing to the clerk prior to
the meeting? Is that Yeah, that's fine.
Okay. Just wanted to make sure. Thank
you. Okay, we have a motion and second
to replace temporary resolution
37-25 with temporary with temporary
resolution
37-25 star as presented to the clerk in
writing before tonight's meeting. Is
there any discussion? Council member
Wolfinger.
Uh there has been a slight adjustment in
the we're going to have one FTE versus
two FTEES which will be which will
change the dollar amount and it will be
uh for eight months to the end of the
year. Okay. Thank you. So
um please call the role on the motion to
replace Mr. Als. Yes. Mr. Bisjack. Yes.
Mrs. K. Yes. Mrs. Hoop. Yes. Mr.
Luckenberg. Yes. Mr. Skunover. Yes. Mr.
Sully, yes. Miss Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes. Motion to
replace temporary resolution 37-25 with
temporary resolution 37-25 star passes
10 to zero. Council member Wolfinger.
Yes, Mr. President. I'd like to make a
motion that council suspends its rules
and waves the third reading of temporary
resolution 37-25.
Second. We have a motion and second to
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary resolution
37-25 star. Any discussion? No further.
Thank you. Please call the Yes. May Mr.
Mayor for council's um information. I'd
like to add a couple things on this. So,
I met with Valita Sloan, our clerk of
courts, regarding this uh ordinance
request to add employees. Uh, I just
want you to know that she was willing to
change her request and go with one
employee to see what kind of burden the
office is going to have. She's discussed
this with her staff. Um, I just want to
assure I I assured her that we would
revisit this. It ends up being the
workload she anticipated originally.
We're hopeful that it won't be. We're
hopeful that one employee will work. Um,
and she was willing to do that and work
with us so that we could make this
happen, get the help she needs. We know
this is a huge
burden, an unfunded mandate from the
state, a law change that doesn't make a
lot of sense to me, but yet it did
change. And now her office is tasked
with complying with the law that went to
effect earlier this month. So, this one
person is going to be helpful, but I
just wanted council to know that if that
burden is so much that she might come
back for help later this year, early
next year, but I told her we would take
her information and and we would look at
it at that time if it happens. I'm
hopeful, she's hopeful that one will.
So, I just wanted to put that on the
record. Thank you, Mr. Mayor. Any
further discussions on the motion to
suspend? I I understand the situation
that we're in. This is essentially an
unfunded mandate from the state. Um I do
think it's fair that we maybe ask the uh
county for some help with this. I mean,
I understand this is the middle of the
year. They don't like to, you know, add
any add to their budget in the middle of
the year, but it's not in our budget
either. I'll be happy to reach out to
them. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Any
further discussion on the motion to
suspend? Hearing none, please call the
role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisshack, yes.
Mr. Mrs. Kites, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Luenberg, yes. Mr. Skinner, yes. Mr.
Sully, yes. Miss Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes. Motion to
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary resolution
37-25 star passes 10 to zero. Now, back
to council. One more time. Yes, council
member Wolfinger. Thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and crosse and enter
upon excuse me the written record
temporary resolution 37-25
star
37-25 star star. Thank you. Yep. Second.
Thank you. I have a motion and second to
pass and grow enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 37-25 star.
Uh any further discussion hearing? None.
Please call the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr.
Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kates, yes. Mrs.
Hoop, yes. Mr. Lockenberg, yes. Mr.
Skoonberg, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes.
Motion to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
37-25 star passes 10 to zero. We will
now move on to the first reading of
resolutions beginning with temporary
resolution 38-25.
a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services
associated with flow monitoring to be
conducted within the river valley
highlands subdivision sanitary sewer
system. This is through water water
pollution um committee Mr. Wing and Miss
Ste. Council member Wing. This is the
first of three readings. First of three
readings on temporary resolution 38-25.
Temporary resolution 39-25,
a resolution to increase receipt
appropriated funds in in the wastewater
reserve fund 6029. Amend the certificate
of other sources and appropriations with
the county auditor and authorize
payments of bills and then announce
certificates for the Ohio water
development loan for the solids handling
facility upgrade project. This is
through water water pollution committee,
Mr. Wing and Mr. Als council member Wing
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary resolution
39-25 temporary resolution
40-25 a resol a resolution to increase
receipts appropriate funds in the storm
utility reserve fund
6019 appropriate the certificate of
other sources and appropriations with
the county auditor and authorized
payments of bills with then and now
certificates for the Ohio water
development loan for the east main
Street Sewer Separation Project. This is
through water water pollution committee.
Mr. Wing and Miss Tiner. Council member
Wing. First of three readings. First of
three readings on temporary resolution
40-25. Temporary resolution 41-25.
A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to dispense with
competitive bidding due to a sole source
provider for membrane replacement for
the Upper Hawking water pollution
control facility. Again, this is through
water water pollution committee. Mr.
Wing and Mr. Als, Council Member Wing,
this is also the first of three
readings. First of three readings on
temporary resolution
41-25. Temporary resolution 42-25.
A resolution to authorize the city of
Lancaster to apply for funding from the
Ohio Department of Development for CHIP
program funds. This is economic
development committee, Miss Hoop and
Mrs. Great. Council member Mrs. Great.
Sorry. Council member Hoop. Yes. Thank
you. This is first of three readings.
First of three readings on temporary
resolution
42-25. Temporary resolution 43-25.
A resolution to amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor.
Appropriate from the unencumbered
balance, increase receipts, complete the
fund transfer in the CDBG loan repay
revolving account fund 2075 and in the
commit or community development block
grant fund 2073 and declare an
emergency. This is through economic
development committee. Mrs. Hoop and Mr.
Wing. Council member Hoop. Thank you.
This is first of three readings. First
of three readings on temporary uh
temporary resolution
43-25. Temporary resolution 44-25.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance. Amend the
certificate with the county auditor in
the cemetery fund
20007 to authorize the service safety
director to purchase a replacement
vehicle for use by the cemetery
department supervisor and to declare an
emergency. This is through public works
committee, Miss Tiner and Mrs. Kra. Mr.
President, I'd like to make a motion
that council suspend it rules and wave
the second and third reading of
temporary resolution 4425. And I'm so
sorry I went over. You're okay. You're
all good. Do we have a second? We have a
We have a motion and a second to suspend
the rules and wave the second and third
reading of temporary resolution 44-25.
Any discussion? I can wait. Okay. Thank
you. U hearing no further discussion on
the motion to suspend. Please call the
role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes.
Mrs. Kes, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Lucknberg, yes. Mr. Skoonver, yes. Mr.
Sullie, yes. Mr. Ter, yes. Mr. Wing.
Yes. And Mr. Wolfinger. Yes. Motion to
suspend the rules and wave the second
and third reading of temporary
resolution
44-25. Passes 10 to zero. Council member
Tiner. Mr. President, I'd like to make a
motion that council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 4425. Second. We have a
motion and second to pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution
44-25. Any discussion? Council member
Tiner. Yes, we had a uh vehicle from the
cemetery department in an accident. Was
not our fault. Uh we did uh get some
insurance money from that. And it's
really e more economical with the age of
the vehicle that was hit that that we
could buy a brand new one that and we'd
put the money towards the purchase of it
and it would be warrant under warranty.
And if we bought something that was
older, we there wouldn't be a warranty.
We'd have to actually pay for a
warranty. And I'm like one of those
people that do not like to buy new
vehicles constantly, but this actually
is uh a better goal than getting a used
vehicle.
Thank you. Any further discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bischack, yes. Miss Kite,
Mrs. Kra, Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Lenberg,
yes. Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes.
Miss Ter, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes. Motion to pass and gross
and enter upon the written record.
Temporary resolution 44-25 passes 10 to
zero. Temporary resolution 45-25.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance in the general fund
10001. Increase receipts appropriate
from the unencumbered balance in the
health insurance management fund
7022 and amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor.
This is through administrative services
committee, Mr. Luckenberg and Mr.
Vijjack. Council member Luenberg. Thank
you, Mr. President. This first of three
readings. First of three readings on
temporary resolution
45-25. That concludes our uh reading of
resolutions for this evening. We will
now move on to the reading of ordinances
beginning with temporary ordinance
19-25.
An ordinance providing for the issuance
and sale of notes in the maximum
principal amount of $7 million in
anticipation of the issuance of bonds
for the purpose of paying the cost of
the renovations and rehabilitation of
the city hall building and otherwise
improving the site therefore together
with an all
necessary thereto and declaring an
emergency. This is through finance
committee Mr. Wolfinger and Mr.
Council member Wolfinger. Thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross enter and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance 19-25.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
19-25. Any discussion? Council member
Wolfinger. Yes. Thank you, Mr.
President. Uh this resolution or this
excuse me this ordinance is to work on
the exterior primarily of city hall as
well as replace an ancient and probably
out of compliance elevator. I hate to
guess how many years old that is. Uh
we've had a lot of uh deterioration of
our sandstone which is a porous uh
material. uh the bell tower and the
foundation but in essence we're
protecting the skin of the building in
order to preserve the building. It's
over 100 years old, 120 some years old
and nothing is being done on the inside.
But if we don't take care of the
exterior, uh the whole building will
create issues greater than this. And u
again it's been a lot of discussion.
service safety director uh indicated
that we'll be going out to bid in the
very near future and we are hopeful that
the bids come in within the confines of
the uh ordinance. Thank you. Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Council member Craig. Um, I just wanted
to thank the administration,
specifically the service safety
director, who has been very responsive
to my multiple questions and emails on
cost comparison and other options that
we've considered. So, thank you. Thank
you. That's all, Council Member Teener.
I understand, you know, I I do history.
I I I understand buildings and and that,
you know, you want to preserve history,
but um thinking this is kind of
excessive. Uh, I think we should even go
even more baby steps than this. This is
a lot of money and I'm just not
comfortable with it at this time. I'm
just not and I haven't been. I remember
what was it last year whatever when they
got the architect. I voted no on that.
That was a lot of money to put out there
when we have a building and a uh
building department and a zoning
department that, you know, could look at
a lot of things, you know. But anyway, I
I will be voting no. I just think it's
too much at this time. Thank you. Any
further discussion from council?
Council member Wolfinger. I I certainly
appreciate your comments and I I agree
with those comments because there
there's a lot of money to spend. Uh if
we would replace city hall, move it to
another location. You're probably
looking at 20 or $30 million. We need to
function with the city hall. Um again,
if you've been on the inside of the
building, there's a lot of deterioration
with the plaster on the walls.
Um, it's one of those things that we
cannot let it deteriorate. Uh, we need
it as our home. So, thank you for your
comments and they're well well spoken.
Thank you. Any further discussion from
council
members hearing? None. Please call the
role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes.
Mr. Mrs. Kates, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes.
Mrs. Mr. Lockenberg, yes. Mr. Munover.
Yes. Mr. Sullie. Yes. Miss Tiner. Nope.
Mr. Wing. Yes. And Mr. Wolfinger. Yes.
Temporary ordinance
19-25 passes 9
to1. Temporary ordinance 20-25.
An ordinance to accept the annexation of
5.08 plus or minus acres in the Pleasant
Township and to declare an emergency.
This is through economic development
committee. Mrs. Hoop and Mrs. Crates.
Council member Hoop. Um, yes, Mr.
President. I would like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 20-25.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
20-25. Any further discussion, council
member? Um, yes. Thank you, Mr.
President. Um, this is just a final
approval to annex the 5 acres um out of
Pleasant Township at the request of Blue
Label Packaging. Thank you. Any further
discussion?
Hearing none, please call the RO. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kra,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Lenberg, yes.
Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Teener, yes. Mr. Wolfinger, yes. And Mr.
Wing, I'm sorry. Yes.
I got ahead of you.
Motion to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary ordinance
20-25 passes 10 to
zero. Temporary ordinance 21-25
an ordinance to amend the zoning map
subject to passage of the annexation of
5.08 plus or minus acres in Pleasant
Township and to declare an
emergency. This is through economic
development committee, Mrs. Hoop and Mr.
Wing. Council member Hoop. Yes, Mr.
President. I would like to make a motion
that council pass engross the matter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 21-25.
Um I think we have to replace it with
21-25 star. Oh, you're right. We do.
Okay. I missed that. Can I address that
real quick? President, thank you. Sorry.
Um so yes, when we initially did the
legislation, that was prior to the um
planning commission's public hearing on
this uh zoning amendment or this um I'm
sorry, the acceptance of this annexation
parcel. Um so I apologize once we get
that done um and accept the annexation
and then the zoning um we have to change
it to reflect when the public hearings
were held um and to make sure that
everything matches what planning
commission allowed us to do. Um, I will
also say after you do a motion to
replace, I am going to ask you to table
it for one one meeting because um,
between the clerk and myself, we kind of
got our wires crossed and we do need to
have a public hearing here at city
council. So, we're going to schedule
that for council's next meeting on May
5th. Um, and at which time, you know,
once it passes, it will be immediately
effective. Thank you. Sorry. No problem.
So, do we need
do we need motion to replace it first?
Yeah. and then we can table it. Okay.
Yep. Thank you.
All right. My turn. Uh, Mr. President,
I'd like to make a motion to replace
temporary ordinance 21-25
um with
21-25 star as given to the clerk prior
as provided the clerk in writing prior
to tonight's meeting. Thank you. I'll
second that motion. We have a motion and
second to um replace temporary ordinance
21-25 with temporary ordinance 21-25
star as provided to the clerk in writing
prior to tonight's meeting. Any further
discussion?
Yes, treasurer. Treasure. This is coming
out of left field. I'm going to lobby
the softball
here. Uh someone asked
me on the way in here today and to
declare an emergency. I believe that
means so it immediately goes into effect
once it passes versus the rule that
states that you wait 30 days and then it
goes into effect. Would you just confirm
that to make sure that I said that
correctly? Yep, that's accurate. If the
city has a proper public purpose, which
is um general health, safety, or
welfare, we're allowed to declare an
emergency so that the the legislation
becomes effective immediately. Perfect.
Thank you very much. Yep. Thank you,
Treasur. Yep. Thank you, treasures.
Certainly appreciate it. Um, any further
discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role on
the motion to replace. Mr. Als, yes. Mr.
Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kates, yes. Mrs.
Hoop, yes. Mr. Lockenberg, yes. Mr.
Skoonover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Ter, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger? Yes. Motion to replace passes
10 to zero.
Council member Hoop. Yes, Mr. President.
And I'd like to make a motion that
council place on the table temporary
ordinance 21-25 star. Second. We have a
motion in a second to place upon the
table temporary ordinance 21-25 star.
This is a non-debatable motion. Please
call the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisj,
yes. Mrs. Kra, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Mr. Luenberg, yes. Mr. Skunover, yes.
Mr. Sully, yes. Miss Ter, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfing motion to table
passes 10 to zero. Now move on to
temporary ordinance 22-25.
An ordinance to amend section
1339.13 of the codified ordinance of the
city of Lancaster entitled wireless
telecommunications. This is to code
enforcement and zoning committee. Mr.
Luckenberg and Mrs. Hoop. Council member
Luckenberg. Thank you, Mr. President.
I'd like to make a motion that council
pass and gross enter upon the written
record ordinance temporarily numbered
22-25.
A second. We have a motion and second to
pass gross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance
22-25. Any discussion? Council member
Luckenberg. Uh yes. Uh this ordinance uh
replaces uh a portion ordinance written
years ago that instructed the city to
maintain and regulate all wireless
telecom telecommunication towers and
since then federal law has placed that
responsibility
uh on the FCC and so we're simply
rewriting that piece of the ordinance uh
with this legislation. Thank you. Any
further discussion on temporary
ordinance 22-25? Mr. President, I'm
going to have to abstain on this one
because due to my current employment.
Thank you. Anything further?
Please call the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr.
Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kes, yes. Mrs. Hoop,
yes. Mr. Luenberg, yes. Mr. Skunover,
yes. Miss Tiner, yes. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes.
Temporary ordinance
22-25 passes 9 to zero with one
abstension.
We will now move on to the second
reading of ordinances beginning with
temporary ordinance
23-25. an ordinance determining that the
establishment of the Lancaster New
Community Authority will be conducive to
the public safety um convenience and
welfare and is intended to result in the
development of the new community in
declaring the new community authority to
be organized by a body politic and a
corporate defining the boundary of the
new committee district and declaring
emergency. This is through economic
development committee Mrs. Hoop and Mr.
Wing. Council member Hoop. Thank you.
This is second of three readings. Second
of three readings on temporary ordinance
23-25. Temporary ordinance 24-25.
An ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance
1-25, also known as the amended nonun
pay ordinance and to declare an
emergency. This is the administrative
services committee, Mr. Luenberg and Mr.
Wolfinger. Council member Luckenberg.
Uh, thank you, Mr. President. I'd like
to make a motion to replace ordinance
temporarily numbered 24-25
uh replacing it with ordinance 24-25
star as given to the clerk in writing
prior to tonight's meeting. Thank you.
Second. We have a motion and a second on
an ordinance on um a motion to replace
temporary ordinance
24-25 with temporary ordinance 24-25
star as provided to the clerk prior to
tonight's meeting. Any further
discussion? Uh yes, we discussed this
earlier in the uh in the meeting wherein
um Belita only needs is only getting one
additional person instead of two. Okay.
And uh All right. Any further
discussion? Uh yes, I apologize,
President Porter. I'm just seeing on the
agenda where it indicates three readings
and I thought we were doing two readings
to match the um the earlier piece um
that amended her down to one full-time
employee because that's what this is the
pay ordinance to reflect. So, do you do
you want us to do a motion to wave the
to suspend and pass? Suspend and pass
tonight. We would do that after we do
the Okay, thank you. Sorry. Yeah, no
problem. Um, so any further discussion
on the motion to replace?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bishack, yes. Mrs. Kes,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Luenberg, yes.
Mr. Scoover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Ter, yes. Mr. Wing or Wing? Yes. Mr.
Wolfinger? Yes. You're trying. I know.
Okay. Motion to replace temporary
ordinance 24-25 with temporary ordinance
24-25 star as provided to the clerk in
writing prior to tonight's meeting.
Passes 10 to zero. Council member
Luckenberg. Uh thank you, Mr. President.
I'd like to make a motion that council
suspend its rules, wave the third
reading of ordinance temporarily
numbered 24-25 star. Second. We have a
motion, a second to pass or to uh
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance 24-25
star. Any discussion on the motion to
suspend?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisch, yes. Mrs. Kates,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Loenberg, yes.
Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Teener, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes. Motion to suspend um
rules and wave the third reading and
temporary ordinance 24-25 star passes 10
to zero. Council member Luckenberg.
Thank you, Mr. President. I'd like to
make a motion that council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
ordinance temporarily numbered 24-25
star.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance 24-25
star. Any discussion hearing? None.
Please call the role. Mr. Eels, yes. Mr.
Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Christ, yes. Mrs.
Hoop, yes. Mr. Luckenberg, yes. Mr.
Skunover, yes. Mr. Sully, yes. Miss
Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinker, yes.
Temporary ordinance
24-25 star passes 10 to zero. There are
no first readings of ordinances this
evening. We would now move to tabled
legislation. There any any action on
tabled legislation this evening?
Yeah.
Okay. So that would council member
crates. Thank you. Mr. President, I
would like to make a motion that council
remove from the table ordinance
temporarily numbered 52-24.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
remove from the table temporary
ordinance
52-24. This is a non-debatable motion.
Please call the role.
Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisch, yes. Mrs.
Kates, yes. Mrs. Hoff, yes. Mr.
Luenberg, yes. Mr. Skunover, yes. Mr.
Sully, yes. Miss Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing,
yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes.
Motion to remove from the table
temporary ordinance
52-24 passes 10 to zero. Council member
Kits. Thank you.
Hello Director Hall. I noticed that it's
on its second
reading. Any reason that we need to take
that we need to do anything? Can we just
leave it on for the next to have three
readings?
Yes.
Although I'm trying to think if we had I
thought we had three readings. We I
think we put it on the table because we
already had the two two readings.
So if you're reading it tonight, then
this is the third reading. Yes. Okay. So
you you can take action on it tonight
now that it's removed from the table.
But did the clerk actually read it? I
didn't hear I didn't yet. She hasn't
read it yet. As soon as you read it.
Thanks. I didn't need it. Okay. Go
ahead. Y an ordinance to grant the South
Central Power Company, its success
successors, and
assigns a franchise for the right to
acquire, construct, maintain, and
operate in the streets their oh my their
affairs, alleys, bridges, and public
places of the city of Lancaster, Ohio,
and its successors. Alliance for the
transmission and distribution of
electric energy to the city of Lancaster
and the inhabitants there thereof for
light, heat, power, and other purposes
and for the transmission of the same
within through our or across said city
of Lancaster and to declare an
emergency. This is through law
committee, Mrs. Kates and Mr. Wolfinger.
Council member Kates. Yes. Thank you,
Mr. President. I would like to make a
motion that council pass engross and
enter upon the written record ordinance
temporarily numbered 52-24.
Second. We have a motion and a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
52-24. Any discussion? Council member
Kits. Yes, just briefly. Thank you. Um
this is to comply with state law. Uh and
we must have an agreement in an
agreement in place uh with the service
provider and the current agreement with
South Central Power has expired. Thank
you. Any further discussion from council
members? Council, this is two years,
right? Council member Tener, it's two
years. We're extending it two years.
The current version 25. This one's going
to 25. Yes. Nobody nobody wanted to
nobody made a motion to replace. Um that
was requested at the last meeting and it
was not approved. So I'm assuming that
Councilwoman Kits knew this was for 25
years. Yes. Correct. Cuz I was under the
impression it was still two cuz that's
what we were doing before. No, it's
never been two years. It's always been
25 um to match what A has. At the last
meeting, South Central Power asked me to
put an amendment out for two years, but
nobody apparently wanted to do that
because it was not moved to be adopted
because I thought the first one was five
and then it's up. No, no, 25. The last
one was 50. 50 years and this one was
25. Yeah, that's the difference. Excuse
me. I'm I don't want to but I just want
to be clear. I am Kyle Kerr, vice
president of legal from South. If you
would come to the podium to address
council at this time. Mr. Thank you. I
just want to be clear. We will not sign
a 25-year agreement.
Okay. Thank you for that input. Wait,
that's why we requested the two years
and I'm happy to entertain any question
that anyone might have of why two years
is more appropriate. That's what we
requested. We will not sign a 25-year
agreement. Therefore, it will have no
effect.
[Music]
Council member Skunover. So you you had
sent out an email
about
changing what we had tabled, right, that
everybody received.
So if we wanted to adopt that, we would
have asked to replace the current
with basically the one that has changes
that they requested. Okay. Yes, sir.
Just making sure that everybody knows
that that was an
option. That was the option.
Okay. Treasurer Stoke. I'll ask the
obvious question. What does that mean if
they don't sign them? Yeah.
So, there's a difference of legal
opinion between the city and South
Central Power. Um, and they have
previously threatened legal action
against the city. So, I'd really rather
not go into all of the particulars on
council floor. Happy to address that in
an executive session if somebody would
like to uh move to have one, but I I
won't be discussing the particulars here
because like I said, they have
threatened legal action
that's a misrepresentation. Okay, we're
not going to get into it. We're Ma'am
Ma'am, you had ma'am, you had your
opportunity. If you could sit down,
we're going to proceed with business. I
understand, but I represent South
Central Power the Cooperative. I
understand and you've said that. Okay,
if you'd please have your seat. I
appreciate you your attendance this
evening. Um, we right now have before us
temporary ordinance
52-24. Um, and is there any further
discussion by council members? M Mr.
President, I'm going to have to abstain
on this one as well because of my
current employment. Thank you. business
relationship.
Any further discussion by council me
council member Skunover?
Um I know that there's already a motion
to
pass or we sticking with that or can we
can I withdraw that withdraw? You can
move to amend the motion parliamentarily
or we withdraw and then consider an
executive session unless everybody's
totally cool with what we're doing.
That's a conversation for you to have
out here. Um, if you want to go into
executive session, um, then you have the
right to do that. Um, I mean, I'm trying
to think.
Am I allowed to make a motion to
withdraw my
Do you want to withdraw or do you want
to amend? Do you know or do you want to
have a conversation before you do either
to withdraw it at this time? Right. You
can if you would like to. It's been
moved and seconded.
I was open. I could call for question.
Did you have a Do you call for question?
Calling the question for Robert's rules
of order, which means you have to take a
vote. It's been motion made and
seconded. Okay. We have a motion in a
second on the current uh to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
uh temporary ordinance
52-24. We've had that called as a
question, which means we do have to take
a vote. Um, please call the role. Mr.
Als, no. Mr. Als, he said no. I'm sorry.
Mr. Bisjack, no. Mr. Kite, Mrs. Kates,
no. Mrs. Hoop,
yes.
Mr. Luenberg, no. Mr. Skunover,
Miss Tiner, abstain.
Mr. Wing,
no. And Mr. Wolfinger? Yes.
Director Hall, did you keep tally as
well? What was your tally? The motion
failed. Thank you. Yep.
Okay. So, temporary ordinance 52-24
um did not pass by a vote of
Three, four, five. I was counting and I
lost. Five to two. Three to two. No,
five to two with two extensions. Mhm.
Five and three. Five to three.
Five to three with two extensions.
Okay, that was weird.
We'll now move on to unfinished
business. Is there any unfinished
business before council this
evening hearing?
None. We'll move to new
business. Any new business before
council this
evening. We'll move to the announcement
of scheduled meetings. Next regular
sessions of council May 5th, 2025 at
6:30 p.m. in council chambers. This will
include a public hearing for New
Community Authority and a public hearing
for Blue Label. Um, also a May 19th,
2025 at 6:30 p.m. in council chambers
for the next regular motion or session.
Do we have any special scheduled
meetings? Well, I have none. Move to the
regularly scheduled committee meetings.
Economic Development Committee, April
24th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall, 1897
conference room. Public Works Committee
May 9th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room. Water Pollution Control
Service Committee May 19th at 7:30 a.m.
City Hall 1897 conference room. Code
Enforcement and Zoning Committee May
22nd. Um, rescheduled from last Friday
at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897 conference
room. And then Law Committee May 23rd at
7:30, City Hall 1897 conference room.
Please go to the reading and bills. Um,
I have MNCO for
$88.89 and then again I have MNCO for
$53.94.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to pay the bills. Second motion, second
to pay the bills. All those in favor,
please signify by saying I. I. All those
opposed, seeing sign. Uh, there's no
need for an executive session. I'd take
a motion to adjourn.
I would like to make that motion. We
adjourn. Second. A motion and second to
adjurnn. All those in favor, please
signify by saying I. I. We're adjourned.
Please remember to sign your legislation
this evening. Thank you.
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home and
Crematory in Lancaster and The Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community. Feel free to give us a
call at
740-653652. Stop in and see us at either
of our two locations, 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore. Respect for
tradition, regard for change.
Hi, I'm Karen Martin with After School
Programs of Lancaster. We're here to
provide programs and services to support
educational, social, and cultural
opportunities for our students. This
month, we're thrilled that Buckeye
Toyota and Buckeye Honda have reached
out once again to offer their support
through their Buckeye Cares program by
making a generous donation with each car
sold this month. Join me and many others
in supporting local business and you
might just find yourself saying that's
how I buck. die.